- But you just turned 50. Congratulations.
- I did.
Thank you. And I'm still
playing video games.
- (laughs)
- I know. You should maybe
give up video games now.
- No, I don't think
so. I love video games.
- Yeah, a half century.
Half century. And it's amazing.
- And it's fun, it's a
nice checkout thing too.
- (laughs)
- I like it. I play video games.
- Oh yeah, I think you meant turning 50.
Yeah, you just check out when you turn 50.
Just give up Matt.
- (laughs)
- You're one foot in the grave.
- No. I think it's so funny
because I'm actually
reading this whole book
on age in general and
it's called Lifespan.
It's really good, you should check it out.
but I think it's only as old as you feel.
- Well, and that is something
I definitely embody.
I, I, my inner child is very alive.
- Me too.
- I talk about ninjas for a living,
I do stand up comedy,
I play video games.
I, I'm 50 only on my driver's license.
- So, and Akbar did something
for you on your birthday,
now before we get his side of the story,
what's your side of the story?
- Okay, so it's my 50th Birthday.
And you know, it's a great
cause for celebration.
So I, I, someone rings my doorbell,
and it's a delivery guy from Pizza Hut
and he says, we have 50 pizzas
for your 50th birthday.
And I'm thinking, I can
maybe get through 32
- Oh my God.
- Maybe, on my best day.
- (indistinct)
- But I'm like all right, you know what,
what a nice way for someone to honor me
by knowing I'm lactose-intolerant
and ordering me a ton of pizza.
- I'm lactose intolerant too.
We're such nerds.
- I know. Pizza, no thanks
- Lactose intolerant
- This isn't just for
me, it's for you too.
- I'm trying to figure out,
what do you get a man
for his 50th birthday?
And I thought, you know, he's a comedian,
He'd, you know, so he could appreciate it
So, what I did is I was
calling A. Smith production.
I spoke to Anthony Storm.
I said, find out where
Matt is going to be.
Those were our EP's.
And I said, where's he going to be?
They told me what time
he's going to be home.
I got it.
I ordered 50 pizza.
I reached out to Pizza Hut.
They hooked me up.
So we got all the pizzas and I turn around
and I said, I need a makeup artist.
So I called Megan Hester,
who does prosthetics.
I get the makeup.
And I turn into, I put a big suit on,
get a whole big suit,
get a Afro wig.
I get the whole nine.
- This Eddie Murphy (indistinct)
- I'm two hours into, into makeup just
to be able to pull off this stunt.
So I then pull up to
Matt's house and I said,
we're going to deliver the pizza.
And my objective was, where I
had to turn into a little bit
of an actor.
- What was my objective?
My objective was, I'm hungry,
I want a slice of pizza
and I want to kick it
inside of Matt's house.
And I just let the rest
kind of just flow with it.
- I'm going to need to
see the tape of this.
- Oh boy.
- So, let's play the tape right now.
- First of all, never take
food from Matt's plate.
- Okay, okay so
- Holy (beep)
- Okay so, let me say this.
- You just like slammed the guy down
like you didn't have pizza to spare
- Hold on, hold on so,
- Can we point it out, I just turned 50.
And what did I do?
I took down an NFL player,
ladies and gentleman, if
the Broncos need somebody.
- Oh my god.
- No, no, stop, stop it Matt. Hold on,
- I'm embarrassing.
- Okay. So I was telling
you that he's not athletic.
- 50 pizzas
and he wouldn't spare some.
- Give me back that pizza.
- I knew for sure that
he was not athletic.
And I knew, if you saw it
and you go back and look at the tape,
I put a Hakeem Olajuwon pivot on him.
I was like, boom, bolt,
and then I turned around, spun,
and I was like, I'm outta here.
I was going to run straight
into the house and something just clicked,
his eyes got big,
and he goes, No!
And I'm like to be tackled by Matt,
it surprised me.
He took me down,
I felt it in my chest.
- (laughs)
- Look at this, I mean,
- He said.
- No, you will not come into this house.
- You said, you said happy birthday.
He said, who is this.
- He was like, you mother.
- Kelly, I go from this guy
and, in my neighborhood,
sometimes I've had people
break into my house
and this guy who is still 6'6,
- And running to go into your house.
- Towards my house and I take him down.
My heart is just pounding.
I'm like, you stay down. Stay down!
And then it's Akbar and I'm like,
I think I just got pranked,
and you just immediately
go to, oh, he got me.
- I had everybody.
I had the pizza man involved,
and I had (indistinct),
I mean Pizza Hut gave us the topper.
We had the warm bags.
We had the pizza, we had everything.
So everything worked out.
We had four camera guys.
It was great.
- That's, what a great friend.
What a fun birthday. That's amazing.
- Honestly, the best gift he
could have given me was footage
of me being semi athletic
on my 50th birthday.
- It's just such a strong
man. Taking him down.
- You just show people,
like hey, this is me at 50.
- Don't ask me to do it now.
- Bet you're house won't
be broken into now.
So that's all I'm saying, no
one's coming near your pizza.